parcourez la france elle est belle elle
est riche et pourtant la misère existe
elle est là présente et bien davantage
qu il ya dix ans chômeurs en fin de
droits jeunes dans l'impossibilité de
trouver un premier emploi femmes seules
obligés de travailler et qui ne trouvent
rien personnes âgées abandonnées à leur
solitude
et pourtant les français savent se
montrer généreux lorsqu'on fait appel à
eux
mais ça ne suffit pas c'est douloureux
problème exige d'autre solution
tous les candidats font des promesses
encore faut-il pouvoir les tenir en
avoir la volonté en avoir aussi les
moyens
raymond barre lui propose des solutions
il fera ce qu'il dit parce qu'avec lui
l'économie de la france sera plus forte
plus riches
la france sera partagé ses richesses
parce que raymond barre est un homme de
coeur avec lui j'en suis sûr
la pauvreté reculera la sécurité sociale
sera préservé les français seront plus
solidaire parce que plus unie puissante
la france pourra aider davantage de
termonde et entraîner nos partenaires
européens dans un vaste mouvement de
solidarité renforcer la solidarité
nationale voilà un grand objectif pour
les prochaines années
la société de liberté que nous voulons a
besoin de solidarité parce qu'il n'ya
pas de liberté s'il n'y a pas de
protection sociale contre les grands
risques de la vie notre économie est en
mutation
beaucoup de français connaissent des
épreuves ils doivent pouvoir les
surmonter grâce à la solidarité
nationale
nous recherchons la compétitivité
l'efficacité
comment pourrions-nous les atteindre
s'il n'ya pas solidarité entre les
acteurs de la vie économique et sociale
madame sur ce sujet important vous avez
bien voulu accepter de m'interroger je
vous en remercie dans les premiers
auxquels on pense quand on parle de
solidarité
et sont ceux qui sont sortis du circuit
économique les retraités on va écouter
deux témoignages et vous allez voir ça
ne va pas très bien je dispose que d'une
petite phrase bloqué pour le moment
c'est un problème parce que comme il ya
beaucoup de rumeurs
comme il ya beaucoup de deux personnes à
la pré-retraite où tout ça et bien il ya
de moins en moins de personnes qui
cotisent et je crois que ça va poser un
problème à tout le monde pour
l'importance du travail que j'ai
effectué je trouve que la retraite n'est
pas suffisante en proportion de ce que
j'ai pu verser tout au long de ma
carrière
il va falloir trouver une autre solution
je crois enfin c'est pas à moi de le
dire
c'est à nos commandes et régionaux élus
de s'en occuper
voilà qui vous est demandé très
gentiment comment on peut faire pour un
meilleur retrait j'ai beaucoup travaillé
je n'ai pas assez c'est ça qu'elle dit
la dame il y a un problème de
financement des retraites les ressources
financières sont pas suffisantes
par conséquent le premier objectif déjà
ambitieux que l'on doit se fixer se
maintenir le pouvoir d'achat des
retraites
si l'économie française va mieux si la
france se renforce
on pourra augmenter les retraites
personnellement j'ai assuré entre 1976
et 1981 le doublement du minimum
vieillesse
il ya d'autres mesures à prendre s'il
n'y a pas de ressources financières
suffisantes dans l'immédiat
on peut recourir à la formule préconisée
par la commission des sages sur la
sécurité sociale un prélèvement
proportionnel sur tous les revenus
j'y suis personnellement favorable
et puis on peut conseiller à ceux qui
vont prendre leur retraite de prolonger
la durée du travail
aujourd'hui la retraite à 60 ans si tout
le monde prend sa retraite à 60 ans le
problème deviendra de plus en plus
difficiles dans les années à venir
passer quand la changeait la jeune entre
nous pas changer l'âge de la retraite
mais il faut inciter ceux qui arrivent à
l'âge de 60 ans à poursuivre s'ils le
désirent leur activité aux besoins en
leur donnant des avantages
supplémentaires sous forme de points qui
permettent d'augmenter le montant de
leur retraite
et puis il faut demander aux jeunes à
ceux qui aujourd'hui sont en train de se
constituer une retraite pour l'avenir de
ne pas se contenter simplement des
systèmes existants que l'on appelle les
systèmes de répartition mais de
développer parleurs et paris des
systèmes de capitalisation
je crois que de cette façon là on pourra
faire face au problème de la retraite
mais pour les fins de droit qui une
situation véritablement dramatique je
crois qu'une mesure immédiate doit être
prise dès que l'élection présidentielle
sera terminé
cette apporter une aide financière
personnalisée à ces hommes et à ces
femmes qui n'ont plus de moyens de
subsistance convenable il ne faut pas
bien sûr transformer leur situation en
situation d'assisté il faut que l'aide
qui leur est accordé leur permet de
retrouver leur liberté leur autonomie
avoir une contrepartie sous forme de
formation d'activité et je crois que de
cette façon là on pourra le rendre leur
dignité
alors vous avez souhaité parler de la
solitude
on va écouter de témoignages la solitude
c'est bien pénible très pénible quand
vous rentrez chez vous quand on est une
compagne pendant le long des années
qu'elle a disparu
on trouve des problèmes des sérieux
problèmes et pour pas pensé on va se
coucher de bonne heure oubliez tout cela
pour alors je prends un livre et je lis
dans mon lit
il accepte d'y aller alors qu'il soit
et maisons accueillant vous pensez
vraiment que la solitude c'est le
problème des gouvernements je n'ai pas
le problème des gouvernements c'est un
problème de société
la population française vit la solitude
s'accroît mais nous avons pendant les
années de prospérité pris des habitudes
qui sont individualistes et égoïstes
vous voyez par exemple les personnes
âgées qui meurt et aviv salle chez elle
ce n'est que quelques jours après qu'on
découvre au cas sont mortes qu'on
découvre leur corps les voisins ne se
sont pas souciés de ce qui arrivait à
des personnes qu'ils rencontrent
notamment tous les jours et un contre
sale état l'état ne peut rien faire
directement parce qu'il ne va pas mettre
de bons sentiments
les sentiments d'altruisme dans le coeur
des individus mais il y a des gens
égoïstes
il y a des gens qui sont généreux il y à
des associations qui se développe
aujourd'hui pour lutter contre la
solitude de ces personnes qui surtout
dans les grandes villes
même une vie de plus en plus pénible eh
bien l'état peut très bien les aider et
17 vie associative et je crois que c'est
par ce moyen là qu'il peut apporter sa
contribution à plus à ce qu'il y ait
plus de générosité du mouvement dans nos
sociétés
quand on parle de la retraite quand on
parle de la vieillesse on pense
immédiatement à la sécurité sociale
laquelle sécurité sociale comme on le
dit tout le monde le sait est très
malade
on va d'ailleurs entendre là dessus un
témoignage d'expert c'est celui de
l'homme qui en a la charge actuellement
en tant que secrétaire d'état chargé de
la sécurité sociale depuis deux ans je
puis vous dire que dans les toutes
prochaines années la sécurité sociale va
connaître des difficultés financières
considérables notamment au niveau de
l'assurance vieillesse avec un déficit
qui risque de s'accroître au rythme de
10 milliards de francs par an cela se
comprend aisément
il y à chaque année 300 mille retraités
de plus qui vont faire valoir leurs
droits alors que le nombre de cotisants
stan y notamment à cause du chômage n'y
a pas cinquante solutions ou bien on
change le système de sécurité sociale ou
bien en bouche le trou
vous savez qu'on ne changera pas le
système des français y sont faisait pas
ah non les français y sont très attachés
et je crois qu'on peut faire fonctionner
le système si on prend un certain nombre
de mesures
nous venons de parler
blême de la retraite l'avons vu qu'on
pouvait trouver les ressources
immédiates et que l'on pouvait mettre en
oeuvre des moyens qui permettraient à
terme de financer les retraites bien le
problème des allocations familiales
deuxième branche de la sécurité sociale
ce n'est pas ne soulève pas l'heure
actuelle de grandes difficultés
il y à l'assurance maladie pour
l'assurance maladie nous savons bien
qu'il faut discipliner la consommation
médicale et ceci ne peut se faire que si
les acteurs du système assume plus de
responsabilités qu'il s'agisse des
malades ou qu'il s'agisse des médecins
nous savons bien que la gestion
hospitalière doit être réformé qu'on
pourra faire des économies dans ce
domaine et nous savons par ailleurs
qu'il y à des financements
supplémentaires qui devront être
consentis pas du tout en augmentant les
cotisations les entreprises qui payent
déjà beaucoup et qui ne peuvent pas
payer davantage si elles veulent rester
compétitives mais tout en ne sacrifiant
pas le principe de la solidarité tout en
ne substitue repas l'assurance la
solidarité il peut y avoir des
rectifications de frontières et pour un
certain nombre de risques
il est possible de s'adresser par
financement complémentaire à des
mutuelles ou des compagnies d'assurance
alors il y à des milliers de français
que vos paroles ne peuvent même pas
atteindre pour l'excellente raison
qu'ils n'ont pas la sécurité sociale
qu'ils n'ont que rien on les appelle les
nouveaux pauvres c'est quand même très
inquiétant et franchement chacun dans un
pays comme le nôtre ce sont les français
du quart monde
ces français environ 500000 qui n'ont
aucune couverture sociale
il faut qu'il puisse obtenir une
assurance individuelle
parfois ils n'ont pas les droits
nécessaires pour contracter cette
assurance
ils n'ont pas l'argent pour payer il est
donc que nécessaire de le reconnaître
des droits supposé et de dégager des
ressources provenant la solidarité
nationale qui permettront d'assurer la
cour
lecture sociale de ces français quand on
parle de la difficulté qu'il ya à
financer les retraites et la sécurité
sociale
on dit il n'ya pas assez de cotisants et
ya passé cotisants tout simplement parce
qu'il ya passé français il n'y a pas
assez de jeunes français il en faudrait
trois à voir pourquoi ils n'en font pas
3 à cause du gros aimant pour moi
d'arrêter de travailler avec un
troisième
moi que salaire que je fais non c'est
hors de question
c'est même pas si bien sûr mais je
préfère avoir d'autres avoir d'enfant
mais maintenant c'est tout bien réfléchi
en question j'ai trois enfants c'est en
4 ans et 9 mois
les allocations familiales j'ai eu droit
à la prime de congé parental mais c'est
pas suffisant ça ne remplace pas un
salaire donc je suis obligée de
retourner travailler
penser que les français sont égoïstes et
qu'il faudrait qu'ils se dévouent pour
faire un troisième enfant parce que ça
leur faisait quand même à vannes le
premier oui jo et problème et il faut
les aider à résoudre ces problèmes
évidemment c'est un problème de société
par exemple l'organisation du travail
ce n'est pas à l'état de modifier les
conditions d'organisation du travail
dans les autres pays il ya un temps
partiel et les horaires flexibles l'état
déjà fait voter des lois sur le temps
partiel
encore faut-il que les entreprises
acceptent de l'impliquer par ailleurs
les questions qui sont soulevées par les
sens du troisième enfant sont pas
seulement des questions financières
il ya par exemple problème logement ce
que l'état peut faire à mon sens et ne
pas faire les enfants alary non non non
mais l'état ne peut jamais faire je
crois qu'il faut comprendre que l'état
doit faire faire même les enfants
c'est la raison pour laquelle je crois
qu'il faut donner des moyens
supplémentaires aux familles qui veut
qu'ils ont un troisième enfant et plus
j'ai proposé le doublement de
l'allocation parentale d'éducation dont
parle cette jeune femme questions sur
trois sur trois ans on peut apporter là
une aide financière intéressante ou bien
pour certaines femmes qui veulent avoir
des enfants plus rapprochés on peut
mettre union le montant de l'allocation
parentale mais étendre le versement de
cette allocation sur une période de six
ans et laisser la femme en fonction du
fait de sa stratégie maternelle choisir
la formule qui convient le mieux
vous pensez que le temps partiel ou le
mi-temps est une bonne réponse à la
période d'éducation des enfants pour les
femmes parce que ça nous dire quand même
pas tout la ville des maisons les autres
pays dont les autres pays le temps
partiel
et les horaires flexibles sont le plus
largement pratiqué que chez nous mais je
crois qu'une amélioration des conditions
de travail favoriserez cette possibilité
pour la femme de concilier c'est sur son
désir de vie de famille sans venir le
voir des enfants et son aspiration à
travailler la solidarité est ce vraiment
l'objet de lois est ce que c est ce que
c'est un à l'état d'organiser la
solidarité
non madame l'état ne peut pas organiser
la solidarité la solidarité c'est comme
je l'aï dit tout à l'heure un problème
de société un problème de conscience
sociale nos sociétés qui ont aidé des
sociétés prospérité ont été égoïste très
individualiste dans la crise dans le
malheur
on re découvre l'importance de la
solidarité ce que l'état doit faire
c'est aider ceux qui contribuent à cette
prise de conscience et ceux qui
permettent de développer cette prise de
conscience
l'état doit les aider en un mot l'état
doit encourager tous ceux qui veulent
mettre un peu plus de chaleur humaine
dans notre société